on commence lors une interview raté son
plateau de nulle part ailleurs à
l'époque jean claude van damme à l'euro
à ambazac kawato 1re au magistral
pendant le jt avec d'année animaux
rappellent plus où ça et le mec très à
l'aise à s'inviter rang edouard balladur
co invente la fast politique la
politique rapide si vous préférez
élections le dimanche la vie j'appelle
le premier ministre et le mardi
y'a pas de quoi est ce qu on y va du
rater complètement ou s'étant 88 dans
champs elysées michel drucker interdit à
crocodile dundee le méga endormi à la
djette l'axé 5 sinon il s'endort
vraiment pour rien et j'attends jacques
chaillot
paul hogan vient en france pratiquement
pour la première fois il a choisi champs
elysées alors on le remercie vraiment
merci beaucoup d'être parmi nous ce soir
quand mike crocodile dundee arrive à new
york on a l'impression qu'il arrive sur
une autre planète
est ce que c'est exactement ce qui s'est
passé quand vous êtes venu vous
d'australie pour la première fois aux
états unis à new york en particulier
on était nécessaire
qu'est ce que votre question que vous
avez dit qu'en france est le pays
andorre le magazine
[Applaudissements]
on adore et ça tu sais pas quoi de faire
enfin soit tu te retrouvais car tu fais
quoi
ils viendront kodak de dix journées
alors et alors c'est que ces crocodile
dundee
on sait quoi j'ai vu cent fois ce serait
une autre interview pratique
alex hepburn que j'embrasse voilà je
fais des bisous j'ai souvent sur un
stand et m on fait des bisous on avait
un traducteur en régie jeu et sauf qu'au
bout de deux phrases on s'est rendu
compte qu'en fait elle était
complètement bilingue et moi je
m'emmerde et tu reviens vite
je sais que vous êtes vous venez decosse
c'est pourquoi la pl traducteur
mais oui je suis français
hanouna tunisie la goulette francophone
francophile comment elle va ça marche
toujours
ça m'a pris longtemps pour apprendre
mais dix ans en fait elle pas hyper bien
français alors que voulait te voir faire
la traduction être ça c'est alex et moi
et moi chaque ce que c'est et je suis
fan
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai vendu ce même les gens là oui j'ai
un vrai scoop par rapport à sa partie
quoi ouais bon sur la vie de ma mère que
c'est vrai c'est quoi j'ai reçu un
message sur instagram
il ya longtemps d'une alex hepburn
échappé je me suis dit c'est pas
possible ça soit elle et je vais sur son
compte et je voyais à le petit truc
certifié brécéenne je me suis fait
guedra par alex hepburn en basse alex
vraiment longs mois a écrit sa palette
est très jolie la veille dans le sud
plus que ça mais ça m'a surpris c'est
que monsieur c'est quand même une star
vous êtes déjà fait draguer par une
offre connue mais vous dit pas non mais
t'as déjà plus chaude 9 connu toi je me
suis fait draguer par oui ces mots
gildas non c'était chez su raison garder
bah ouais ah oui ah oui tu es libre en
sera vraiment la tête par contre là la
tête c'est jane fonda les masses et jane
fondu
[Applaudissements]
imaginez la dimension de cette femme qui
est formidable et même encore maintenant
je sais attend l'adorent et s'était fait
l'écho d'un dira jamais si quelqu'un
vous avez un homme en sommes ce taux à 1
ils m'ont des chaudronniers pas que je
suis chaud là et on aime on a toujours
le nain qui tombe
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
10 reggae oui voilà accès par wi fi non
mais attends toi c'est ce rêve c'est une
chaussure
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oui c'est que j'ai rencontré oui bon
c'est quand il venait en france et on
avait partagé une émission télé il a été
très très con una méthode coué oui la
merde ya une différence entre être
sympathique et draguer l'ag qui drague
mais attendez il avait déjà des fêtes
depuis de grands crus mais là
alors ce soir c'était à nos invités dans
la grande bercail a si longtemps le ph
il ya des pjcci pascal avec pascal
légitimus mais on n'a ici rien passé
mais on sait draguer un moment avant
première le cinéma il était seul j'étais
seul voilà il est marié aussi j'ai dit
il ya longtemps
jaloux tu vas ils étaient trois frères
c'est bizarre parce qu'il était assis à
côté de moi et il m'a montré tout le
monde qui fait rage
[Applaudissements]
vraiment j'étais cet échec social est
mignonne elle
bravo laurent ce que toi tu dis est dit
les vraies d'hostun alors magloire
magloire en là je sais même pas ce genre
partant c'est lui qui drague il vient de
draguer pardon magloire raphaël mezrahi
il ya à peu près quelques minutes
[Rires]
mais quel ballon un peu plus à côté de
moi avons moi je vais balancer après
tiffany machine et en mon nom à la série
américaine
si on dit la vérité à la radio proto et
dragon search y avait quoi
ménard est trop tard salmi contre
sortent et se baisser et j'ai été obligé
lui dire tu es comme ma soeur dit fanny
j'aimerais que vous sortiez une vraie
personne
ouais vous aimez beaucoup vous des
finances sortant des doigts la gaule au
comme ça mais j'aimerais que vous sortez
une vraie personne qui vous a légué par
ci une vraie star personne mais si je ne
vois pas c'est bien non ce livre on est
là on rigole attendait plus rien voilà
bah vous avez raison maintenant vous
avez dit
sentimentalement h ampérage joli ça on
va dire ça glisse et libanais mais
laurence est célibataire tiffany aussi
toi tu es russo tu vas reparti raconte
annoncé nous empruntons doit valoir
cette auto sport l'a rongé catagolfe
après paris
[Rires]
une autre interview matic
on a beaucoup vu juste en 2017 c'est sur
la chaîne la bbc et robert kelly
professeur de sciences politiques et
spécialiste de l'asie était en fait je
suis persuadé en direct à quoi tu penses
débarque dans son bureau et s'adonne
shifting non
[Applaudissements]
j'ai trois dernières interviews raté qui
sont très drôles c'est une journaliste
hollandaise qui fait une interview sur
un bateau la meuf elle prend la
confiance au bateau elles se sont bien
ressaisis au début voilà c'est compliqué
après ça y est elles sont bien et voilà
ces problèmes baptisé nazo bisons de
rester au camp projet de motion
[Applaudissements]
c'est exceptionnel c'est vraiment c'est
on voit que la pauvre elle ne s'y attend
pas de titanic
je la connais la pression face à une
autre interview raté c'était pendant un
concours de motocross en pologne
moi j'ai aussi la télé polonaise alors
tout se passe bien jusqu'au départ d'un
motard garder suis là et c'est en fait
c'est les prémices du chocolat gates
regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
justin vase
je pense qu'être me c'est vrai c'est
tellement drôle mais ça aussi c'est
exceptionnel croyant les mêmes fait
plaisir on passe un très gros ratés mais
très très drôle cessé sur l'émission de
télé flamand de boomerang
alors là que le présentateur recevra en
direct des victimes d'erreurs médicales
et il n'a pas pu retourner souffre
obtenir son sourire face à la voix hyper
aiguë sont innombrables et c'est là
c'est moi c'est le truc qui m'a fait le
plus grossier vidéo que j'ai vu de ma
vie
mam aussi voilà c'est ça vous et c'est
ça et vous tenu à excuser un premier
temps tout comme si c'était l'année de
chick d'attentes maroc je me sentais
libre
[Musique]
mais un coup j'étais technique excusez
la mairie kingdon et québec celle des
ménages les bennes vertes de gagner
évoque les questions de ce thème
[Applaudissements]
alors ça lolo c'est bidonné ça je crois
que c'est le présent le présentateur qui
est piégé bassin bidonné donc si toi
aussi
non mais si oui mais en fait c'est un
faux gars comme ça ouais mais le focus
est sûre le mec qui se marre donc un
boulot aussi voilà les ronds ça passe ça
génial extrêmement drôle les chiffres on
se rate et on suit un petit peu de rater
encore c'est ton 2016 pendant les
primaires de droite en plateau y avait
daniel cohn bendit qui invitait pour
commenter la large victoire de françois
fillon oui c'est à l'époque où françois
fillon gagné ray-ban c'était avant
l'histoire des costumes tout ça est
placé s'arrêter là la descente aux
enfers alors laurent delahousse annonce
que jean luc mélenchon et en duplex pour
qu'il puisse à son tour donner son avis
et là bas c'est tranquille ou perdre on
m'a dit j'aimerais vous poser une
question il va vous la posez tout de
suite jean luc jean luc si tu te
présentes à la primaire tu peux lâcher
andy est ce que vous pouvez m'appeler
par mon nom et pas par mon prénom s'il
vous plaît nous ne sommes pas amis vous
le savez ne joue pas la comédie va te
faire voir mieux voilà moi je vous avais
rien demandé monsieur cohn bendit gardez
votre calme ça vaudrait mieux pour
qu'ils oublient c'est toujours bon les
soirées électorales pas je sais qu'on va
se régaler à ce que tu as les perdants
ils sont à l'aise d'aller sur les
plateaux mais sont obligés d'y aller et
les gagnants ils sont épaulés font les
beaux gosses sur le bateau et son gaz a
coûté les français vous parler ainsi
vous plaît les chiffres sont là
faites vous tout petit rachida dati a
dit rachida dati en gardant suis désolé
cette première en politique qui me
stimule inscrit la première voilà j'ai
une autre interview mythique c'était
dans ce port 3 dimanche en 91
le journaliste georges dominique temps
d'interviewer le mal jean-luc assez mal
tu te rappelles de certainement drôle il
court après et pendant le marathon des
bien sûr à l'époque des filets
c'est un mot tendance
avant ce moteur bordel attend donc pas
tort
à toi tu vas
je vais être essoufflée moi mon pote
l'attendre plusieurs cas tu ne seriez
très loin devant en temps
jean-luc vous êtes en quelle position
tant que nos positions aujourd'hui
troisième vous connaissez les deux kivu
pressel tanzanien
tant mieux pour lui non non non non non
non
[Applaudissements]
santana tant mieux pour lui